[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen an diesem Samstag den Sport den
hat Rudi Cerne für Sie hallo schönen
guten Abend und wir beginnen mit einer
unerwarteten Wendung die Bahn steht doch
nicht still
angekündigter Bahnstreik abgesagt vor
dem Arbeitsgericht einigen sich
Gewerkschaft und Deutsche Bahn auf einen
Vergleich
Bundesregierung geht bisher größte
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine Präsident
selenski kommt erstmals seit
Kriegsbeginn nach Deutschland
und Countdown in Liverpool Musikfans in
aller Welt fiebern dem Eurovision Song
Contest
[Musik]
Riesenüberraschung für alle die mit der
Deutschen Bahn fahren der große
Warnstreik ist abgesagt eigentlich hätte
nach dem Willen der Gewerkschaft EVG ab
morgenabend so gut wie kein Zug im fern
und Nahverkehr fahren sollen und zwar
gut zwei Tage lang aber im letzten
Moment einigten sich Bahn und
Gewerkschaft auf einen Vergleich vor
Gericht und das bedeutet fast alle Züge
fahren und im Tarif Streit wird wieder
verhandelt der Einzelheiten von Klinge
Erleichterung auf Seiten der Bahn es war
ein zähes Ring vor dem Arbeitsgericht in
Frankfurt die Deutsche Bahn hatte einen
Eilantrag eingereicht um den Streik doch
noch zu stoppen sie sieht Forderungen
der eisenbahngewerkschaft EVG im Bereich
des Mindestlohns bereits als erfüllt an
der Vergleich für die Bahn ein positives
Zeichen im Tarifkonflikt vor allem auch
für Reisende
wir können sich darauf einstellen dass
am Montag und Dienstag sehr umfassender
Bahnverkehr stattfinden wird die wurde
nicht ganz alle Züge fahren werden aber
im Wesentlichen wird man normalen
Bahnverkehr haben und wir müssen uns
jetzt vor allem darauf konzentrieren
dass wir die Informationslage die
Fahrplänen die Fahrplandaten damit die
Kunden wie gewohnt ihre Fahrpläne auch
einsehen können dass wir die
wiederherstellen die Gewerkschaft EVG
beriet sich ausgiebig bevor sie dem
Vergleich zustimmte und will nun schnell
mit der Bahn verhandeln wir können
feststellen dass die anderen das
Warnstreiks Erfolg hatte der Arbeitgeber
hat heute vor Gericht unmissverständlich
erklärt dass er unsere Forderungen
zumindestlohn erfüllt sollte der
Arbeitgeber wortbrüchig werden werden
wir erneut zu einem Streik aufrufen das
ist erst einmal keinen Streit gibt ist
für viele Reisende eine Erleichterung
und eine Überraschung
das ist ja genial wie bitte ist jetzt
kein Witz ne ich weiß auch nicht wie
herzlos muss man sein dass man an
Muttertag so einen Schrank ausruft also
das verstehe ich nicht also ich finde
das ganz ganz gut nein tatsächlich würde
ich mich aber freuen wenn die Leute alle
mehr Geld verdienen die EVG betonte das
lediglich der Arbeitskampf bei der
Deutschen Bahn abgesagt wurde für einige
andere Bahnunternehmen gelte der Streik
Aufruf weiterhin
[Musik]
der ukrainische Präsident selenski wird
an diesem Wochenende Deutschland
besuchen kurz vorher kündigte das
Bundesverteidigungsministerium jetzt
weitere Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
im Wert von 2,7 Milliarden Euro an
darunter Munition aufklärungsdrohen mehr
als 100 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge sowie auch
30 Leopard Panzer neuerer Bauart und 20
Marder Schützenpanzer dazu kommen vier
Flugabwehrsysteme ihres Tee Andreas
kühners berichtet
Sicherheitsbereich am 14.5 mit seit
heute unübersehbaren Maßnahmen bereitet
die deutsche Polizei einen
ausnahmebesuch vor die deutsche Politik
auch nicht alles im Milliardenpaket ist
neu aber vieles davon neu hergestellt
natürlich im Vordergrund Munition und
Luftverteidigung darum geht es in
besonderer Weise jetzt und die
gepanzerten Fahrzeuge eben noch dazu das
ist ein wirklich großes Paket und wir
wollen damit deutlich zeigen welche
Verantwortung wir als
Staatengemeinschaft hier übernehmen aber
eben vor allem auch als Bundesrepublik
Deutschland um der Ukraine zu helfen
die Lieferung soll nicht aus der
Bundeswehr sondern aus der Industrie
kommen und muss zum Großteil noch
produziert werden aber es ist vor allen
Dingen der politische Wille da endlich
ohne zu zögern das zu liefern was die
Ukraine braucht
außergewöhnlich die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
heute in unter und über Rom sogar ein
Flugverbot ist verhängt mit einem Airbus
der italienischen Regierung landet
Präsident selensky zu einem weiteren
Auslandsbesuch nach Finnland und den
Niederlanden vergangene Woche sagt heute
auch Italien zu der Ukraine weiter zu
liefern was sie braucht selensky trifft
Staatspräsident Macarella und
Premierministerin Meloni die die Ukraine
trotz traditionell guter Beziehungen zu
Russland stark unterstützen
danke das ukrainische Flaggen heute über
Rom wählen danke für die Einladung danke
Italiener
es ist mir eine große Ehre mit Spannung
erwartet selenskys Gespräch mit Papst
franziskus immer wieder hat der Pontifex
die Neutralität des Vatikan betont und
allgemein für Frieden geworden aber
meist ohne den Angreifer Russland beim
Namen zu nennen Gesprächsergebnis noch
nicht bekannt von Rom aus wird selenski
nach Berlin weiterreisen das erste Mal
seit mehr als vier Jahren die Details
seiner Route sind noch geheim
und auf dem Besuch des ukrainischen
Präsidenten und auf die
Waffenlieferungen blicke ich jetzt mit
shakunta la benegy darunter la
Deutschland sagt der Ukraine ja das
bisher größte waffenpaket zu warum jetzt
man kann das schon als willkommensgeste
verstehen gegenüber wo Leute mir
selensky der morgen hier erwartet wird
das Deutschland hat zwei ja bereits
Waffenlieferungen vor längerer Zeit
schon zugesagt und auch gesagt es
liefert kontinuierlich aber der Umfang
dieses Paket ist das jetzt nur in 8
Tagen innerhalb von nur acht Tagen
geschnürt worden ist der ist schon ein
Signal Boss Pistorius sagte Deutschland
meine ist ernst mit der Unterstützung
das wolle man damit zeigen und das wird
in der Ukraine auch registriert von dort
heißt es dass er in historisches Paket
und Deutschland übernehme jetzt die
Führung nur Vize Außenminister Melnik
zeigt sich leicht enttäuscht dass nicht
alles in dem Paket drin ist was man sich
von ukrainischer Seite derzeit
vorstellen kann aber es ist eben ein
Paket mit dem die Lieferungen umgesetzt
werden die schon versprochen waren was
ist noch zum Besuch selenskys in Berlin
bekannt
wer mit Details erhält man sich hier
zurück das Programm ist aus
Sicherheitsgründen noch nicht
veröffentlicht worden aber man kann
davon ausgehen dass silenski morgen hier
im Regierungsviertel sein wird und
vermutlich den Kanzler treffen wird
vielleicht auch den Bundespräsidenten
und dann steht noch die Frage im Raum
reist er danach weiter nach Aachen denn
dort soll ihm und dem ukrainischen Volk
der Karlspreis überreicht werden das ist
eine Verleihung die am Nachmittag
stattfinden soll dort soll Olaf Scholz
die Laudatio erhalten so steht es im
Programm und das geht natürlich alles
auch ohne den Preisträger persönlich
aber mit wäre dann doch schöner ob es
passiert ist allerdings noch offen danke
schön
großbritannien hatte der Ukraine
vorgestern als erstes Land die Lieferung
von Langstrecken Raketen zugesagt heute
nun meldet Russland sie sein bereits
eingesetzt worden diese Bilder sollen
einen Industriekomplex in der von
Russland besetzten Stadt Lohans zeigen
bei dem Angriff sein aber auch
Wohnhäuser zerstört und Menschen
verletzt worden so der Vorwurf aus
Moskau
Trümmerteile sollen den Einsatz der
britischen Raketen belegen
und aus der besonders umkämpften statt
bachmut meldet die ukrainische Armee
heute weitere Gelände Gewinne und in der
Ukraine ist für uns Tim Krüger Tim wie
ist dieses vorrücken einzuordnen
also diese Meldung über ukrainische
Geländegewinne um bachmut halte ich für
durchaus für merkenswerte was gab es
hier in den vergangenen Wochen und
Monaten eher nicht bislang war es so
dass die russische Seite im bachmut zwar
sehr langsam aber doch stetig
vorangekommen ist und jetzt müssen wir
abwarten ob diese Geländegewinne seitens
der Ukraine weitergehen ob sich
womöglich sogar im bachmut das Blatt
zugunsten der ukrainischen Truppen
wendet oder ob das Ganze diese Aktion
diese Vorstöße womöglich sogar schon
erste Anzeichen der angekündigten gegen
Offensive der Ukraine sind für diese
gegen offen sie bekommen die ähm
Waffenlieferungen die die
Bundesregierung heute angekündigt hat
übrigens wahrscheinlich zu spät aber es
gab hier in der Ukraine für dieses
Milliarden Paket heute von Seiten der
Spitzenpolitiker durchaus viel Lob der
ukrainische Außenminister Kollege hat
aber auch Tempo angemahnt bei den
Waffenlieferungen ganz einfach weil die
Ukraine im Krieg gegen Russland nach wie
vor dringend auf diese Waffen angewiesen
ist danke schön Tim Krüger zur Lage in
der Ukraine
in Israel und den Palästinenser Gebieten
dauert die Gewalt an Versuche Ägyptens
eine Waffenruhe zu vermitteln blieben
bislang erfolglos militante
Palästinenser feuerten zahlreiche
Raketen auf den Süden Israels ab die
israelische Luftwaffe bombardierte
mehrere Häuser im Gazastreifen die
Gewalt waren Dienstag neu aufgeflammt
seitdem starben mindestens 33
Palästinenser und ein Israeli
seit der corona-krise können
angeschlagene Betriebe hierzulande
leichter Kurzarbeitergeld für ihre
Beschäftigten beantragen doch Ende Juni
soll damit Schluss sein sagte
Arbeitsminister Heil jetzt der
Rheinischen Post Grund sowohl in der
Wirtschaft als auch am Arbeitsmarkt
laufe ist derzeit besser als noch im
Herbst befürchtet der vereinfachte
Zugang zum Kurzarbeitergeld hat den
Staat insgesamt
45,5 Milliarden Euro gekostet
Wahlkampf in Bremen morgen wird in
Deutschland kleinsten Bundesland ein
neues Parlament die Bremische
Bürgerschaft gewählt heute ging die
Parteien zum letzten Mal auf Stimmen
fangen Regierungschef bogenschulte SPD
war mit roten Rosen für sich das
bisherige Rot-Grün rote Bündnis würde
gerne weiterregieren die CDU mit
Spitzenkandidat im Hof liegt in den
Umfragen hinter der SPD
und im ZDF Haarstudio ist Bettina
Schausten wie knapp könnte das Rennen
werden
also die SPD liegt hier in den letzten
zwei Wochen nicht weiter aber doch recht
stabil vorne und so kann Bürgermeister
Andreas bovenschulter auch darauf hoffen
diese geradezu historische Scharte für
die SPD vom letzten Mal auszuwetzen als
erstmals seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg die
CDU in Bremen stärkste Kraft wurde die
Stunde als zweiter wohl bereit für eine
große Koalition aber es könnte eben auch
weitergehen mit rot grün rot die
bisherigen Umfragen geben das her knapp
500.000 Wahlberechtigte in Bremen und
Bremerhaven das ist eher eine
Kommunalwahl aber wir werden schon
erleben dass die Ergebnisse
bundespolitisch ausgedeutet werden zum
Beispiel was das der Grünen angeht die
ja wahrlich keinen Rückenwind aus Berlin
geschickt haben oder für die FDP die
zuletzt weil Landtagswahlen immer
schwächelte von Bremen übrigens äh
schauen wir auch in die Türkei auf diese
europäische Schicksalswahl und holen die
ersten Trends ein also insgesamt ein
spannender Wahlabend zu dem wir uns
morgen ab 17
:45 Uhr hier aus dem ZDF als Studium
melden bis dann Bettina Schausten danke
schön
ja es ist eine richtungsweisende Wahl
morgen in der Türkei nach gut 20 Jahren
könnte Präsident Erdogan seine Macht
verlieren
herausgefordert wird davon des
oppositionsbündnisses es sieht nach
einem Kopf von kopfrennen aus wichtig
wird auch sein wer von den beiden die
jungen Menschen für sich gewinnen kann
es gibt fast 5 Millionen erstwählerinnen
und Wähler mehr dazu von Anna Feist
Bilal ist schon etwas aufgeregt morgen
wird er das erste Mal wählen sein Land
und sein Leben könnten ab morgen ein
anderes werden
ich bin 18 und seitdem ich geboren bin
ist Erdogan an der Macht aber ich finde
er missbraucht seine Macht
wohlfühlen er und seine Freunde sich
schon lange nicht mehr in der Türkei
immer wenn ich die Regierung kritisiere
muss ich Angst haben und meine Zukunft
ich habe Angst dass sie alles gegen mich
verwenden
er wird deshalb dem Oppositionsbündnis
und Kemal Grillitsch der Rollo seine
Stimme geben in Umfragen gelten erst
Wähler wie Bilal er als unzufrieden mit
der amtierenden Regierung zum einen die
hohe Jugendarbeitslosigkeit von fast 20%
dazu die stetig steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten doch die türkische
Journalistin nagelscher waren vor zu
schnellen Schlüssen meistens sagen die
Leute da ist die erst Fehler er für
Christen werden
aber da bin ich mir nicht so sicher
viele sehen in ihm immer noch die starke
Führungsperson sie geht davon aus dass
bis zu 35% der Jungwähler für Erdogan
stimmen könnten der betont bis kurz vor
Wahlkampfabschluss im Hörsaal sein
Engagement
wir haben die 18-Jährigen ins Parlament
geholt die Opposition verspottet uns
dafür holt ihr jetzt schon Kinder Fragen
die bei der 21-Jährigen Emine zieht das
Erdogan stehe immer für sein Volk ein
findet sie deshalb stehe sie hinter
ihrem Präsidenten trotz der schweren
Lage die jungen Menschen leiden etwas
unter der wirtschaftlichen Situation
aber wir werden diese Tage gemeinsam
überstehen
Bilal sieht das anders für ihn steht
fest sollte Erdogan an der Macht bleiben
dann wird er die Türkei verlassen
und jetzt geht's nach Liverpool zum
Eurovision Song Contest die Briten
tragen die Veranstaltung wegen des
Krieges für den vorjahres-sieger Ukraine
aus
2022 hatte die Band Carlos Orchestra die
meisten Punkte geholt seit Tagen wird
geprobt damit heute ein
milliarden-publikum weltweit auf seine
Kosten kommt für Deutschland tritt die
Gruppe Lord of the lost an Andreas Stamm
berichtet
musik liegt in der Luft
Europas Vielfalt auf engstem Raum kurz
es ist Finaltag beim ESC der größten und
buntesten Musikshow der Welt
die selbstgemacht in der Jacke stecken
Wochen an Arbeit aber in der Stadt ist
so viel Glitzer und Glanz einfach
fantastisch
vereint durch Musik darum geht es alle
Menschen die Länder Europas zusammen zu
bringen zu einer großen glücklichen
Gemeinschaft
Europas Einheit zeigt sich diesmal in
blau-gelb überall in der Beatles Stadt
wird die Kultur des verhinderten
Gastgebers gefeiert an den Krieg
erinnert vor dem Olga und ihre Tochter
fliehen mussten
Herzen Danke ich den Menschen in
Großbritannien wir lieben und schätzen
euch
die Menschen hier sind großartig aber
ich vermisse zu Hause danke für Europas
Unterstützung
ein kleiner Schatten über Liverpool der
Streit ob der ukrainische Präsident zu
Wort kommen darf was der Veranstalter
ablehnt als zu politisierend denn im
Mittelpunkt soll Musik und Spaß stehen
die Damen aber ich glaube
der Favorit
[Musik]
gejagt von Finnland
Israel
[Applaus]
oder doch eine Überraschung für die ist
Deutschland auf jeden Fall gut
[Musik]
mit Lord of the lost und nicht wieder
eine lange Nacht der Zero points der
null Punkte
und gefeiert wurde gestern Abend auch in
Berlin dort ist der Deutsche Filmpreis
verliehen worden mit der goldenen Lola
für den besten Film wurde das
Lehrerzimmer ausgezeichnet auch die
Hauptdarstellerin in dem Drama gewann
eine Lola Leonie Prinz
der Preis für den besten Hauptdarsteller
ging an Felix Kamera für seine Rolle im
Film im Westen nichts Neues der neuen
Lolas gewann der Regisseur bekam den
Ehrenpreis
[Applaus]
in der Fußball-Bundesliga ist Bayern
München ja wieder auf Titel Kurs genau
das passt da gut zu die Feiern
wahrscheinlich heute auch nach einem
überzeugenden Auftritt am dritt letzten
Spieltag der Saison der FC Bayern
München also hat im Titel Duell mit
Borussia Dortmund wieder mit einem Sieg
vorgelegt der deutsche Rekordmeister
deklarierte den abstiegsbedrohten FC
Schalke 04 mit 6:0 Verfolger dortmund
spielt noch am Abend gegen Gladbach die
samstags Ergebnisse Bayern München mit
dem souveränen 6:0 gegen Schalke
wichtiger Sieg für Union Berlin im Kampf
um den Champions League Platz vier zu
zwei gegen Freiburg Eintracht Frankfurt
Mainz 3:0 Wolfsburg Hoffenheim 2:1
Bochum gewinnt nach zuletzt sechs
sieglosen Spielen 3:2 gegen Augsburg das
Abendspiel Dortmund gegen Gladbach
ausführlich bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio gestern Köln gegen Hertha
5:2 in der Tabelle die Bayern also jetzt
wieder mit vier Punkten vor Dortmund
Union Berlin zumindest bis morgen
Dritter Leipzig kann dann wieder vorbei
ziehen
Eintracht Frankfurt verbessert sich auf
Platz 8 auch Köln hat eine Position gut
gemacht jetzt auf 10 der VfL Bochum als
15 nach dem Sieg heute auf einem nicht
Abstiegsplatz Schalke rutscht auf 16
härter bleibt Tabellen letzter
alles zum Bundesligaspieltag heute Abend
im Aktuellen Sportstudio von 23 Uhr an
zu Gast ist dann Eintracht Frankfurts
Präsident Peter Fischer die Bonner
Basketballer haben das Finale der
Champions League erreicht der
Bundesliga-Spitzenreiter gewann das
Halbfinalspiel des final Ford Turniers
bei Gastgeber Malaga mit 69 zu 67
Freude bei den Bonner Spielern Champions
League Finale Einzug gegen Malaga in
Malaga nach dramatischen Halbfinale
Kendrick Berry bester Werfer bei den
Spaniern auf Bonner Seite DJ Shorts der
unterschiedsmacher er auch mit dem
letzten dem 69 Bonner Punkt Malaga kommt
dann noch mal dran auf zwei unglaubliche
Spannungen Patrick Perry
vorbei es reicht für 69 67 morgen
greifen die Baskets nach dem ersten
Champions League Titel der
Vereinsgeschichte
[Musik]
und mit einer Niederlage ist die
deutsche Eishockey Nationalmannschaft in
die WM gestartet in Tampere in Finnland
unterlag die Mannschaft des neuen
Bundestrainers Harolds gestern Schweden
mit 0:1 den Treffer für den 11 jährigen
Weltmeister erzielte Oskar Lindberg in
der 42 minute als heute Abend wird das
deutsche Team erneut gefordert und zwar
gegen den aktuellen Weltmeister Finnland
und in der Handball European League der
Frauen ist der Traum vom deutschen
Finale geplatzt Borussia Dortmund spielt
in diesen Minuten sein Final Four
Halbfinale der Thüringer HC ist
allerdings schon ausgeschieden Thüringen
startet respektlos ins Duell mit dem
großen Turnier Favoriten ikas handballt
Sonja Frey mit der frühen 3:1-führung
danach aber zeigt sich warum die Dänen
für ihre Robustheit gefürchtet sind
schnell reißen sie diese Halbfinalpartie
an sich getragen von ihrer überragenden
schwedischen Torfrauen Jessica reitet
ziehen sie unwiderstehlichter von 17:10
die Pausenführung in der zweiten Hälfte
halten die Dänen in den HC Thüringen
routiniert auf Distanz 31 zu 26 der
Endstand
erstmal verwundert die Augen reintreibt
ein altes U-Boot ist zur Zeit auf dem
Rhein unterwegs es wird auf einem
Kontrolle den Fluss hochgebracht des
Speyer danach 40 km bis zu sein Ziel dem
Technikmuseum in Sinsheim
vor 13 Jahren war das U-Boot U17 noch
für die Marine im Einsatz
nach einem sonnigen Start wird es morgen
wieder gewitterig mehr dazu gleich von
öst Intelli und 22.45 können sie es
heute schon mal sehen mit Anne Gellinek
bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir bekommen es
mit einem neuen tief zu tun und das mit
einer etwas ungewöhnlichen Zugbahn von
Süd nach Nord von Italien startet das
tief und zieht in den Osten Deutschlands
schrammt hier vorbei und am Montag sogar
bis hoch nach Skandinavien wir schauen
in die Nacht da tröpfelt es an den Alpen
etwas sonst ist es sternenklar ganz im
Westen da bildet sich Nebel bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 4 Grad Richtung
Vogtland und 10 Grad zum Beispiel
Richtung Nordsee morgen am Vormittag in
der Nordhälfte viel Sonnenschein auch
Richtung mein hier sind nur harmlose
Wolken unterwegs zeigt sich die Sonne
häufig ansonsten im Süden des Dichter
bewölkt mit etwas Regen und zum
Nachmittag kommt dort auch als kräftiger
Regen an mit vielen Wolken nach Osten
zeigt sich durchaus mal die Sonne aber
ansonsten im Norden schauen und Gewitter
und nach Westen hin auch und da kann
auch mal
klar kriegen dabei sein die höchsten
Temperaturen 23 Grad in der Nordhälfte
in der Südhälfte kaum über der 20 Grad
Marke die nächsten Tage weitere shower
vor allem am Montag zieht das Tief
weiter nach Norden und macht es
wechselhaft damit ein schöner Abend